here's what's in theaters this weekend  who are you I'm gonna help yourself in  the spine-tingling thriller incarnate a  scientist enters the mind of a possessed  boy to face the demon head-on I'd like  to thank you the chance to become a star  directed by Warren Beatty rules don't  apply is a romantic comedy about an  actress  her driver and their billionaire boss  mean in this town aren't those the rules  the rules don't apply to you there's  over five million of us and we're on a  cutthroat lobbyists will do anything to  win in the nail-biting political  thriller miss Sloan it's about making  sure you surprise them and they don't  surprise you here's this week's fantasy  patient  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know by commenting below see  you next time on weekend ticket